accompagnement des seniors garde
d'enfants ou encore ménage et repassage
ce sont quelques-uns des services à la
personne proposés en france dans cette
agence versaillaise 19 postes en cdi
sont à pourvoir sur la base du smic
horaire
nous mutualisons
très souvent nos employés pour leur
offrir une diversité plus large
non pas qu'ils pour ne pas qu'il fasse
que la mine que du ménage et repassage
ou que de la garde d'enfants mais leur
pouvoir leur permettre de faire c'est de
ses deux métiers et donc ce qui peut
constituer un temps plein aucun diplôme
particulier n'est demandée sauf pour la
garde d'enfants de moins de 3 ans pour
laquelle il faut un c ap petite enfance
le français lu écrit parlé
la maîtrise du français et puis
et puis un peu d'expérience quand même
que ce soit en ménage aux ménages
industrielle par rapport à ce que l'on
peut penser ça reste un vrai métier et
donc tout le monde sait pas faire le
mélange donc c'est bien d'avoir un petit
peu d'expérience cette agence emploie
actuellement une centaine de personnes
chaque année plus de deux millions de
français font appel aux services à la
personne